I'm going to start by saying been a fan
of your work for a very long time it's
great to talk to you thank you
I have to listen I'm here to talk about
morning show yeah I loved leftovers
thank you loved and so I have to ask you
have you ever said what you think
happened in the finale of the leftovers
like your personal tape or is it that
you kept that close to your vest I don't
think I've ever said it out loud so I'll
ask you do you think she went through
this is what I think I think that people
have belief systems and I think that she
believes she went through because I
think we all need stories to tell
ourselves to get through this life you
know we tell ourselves stories so that
we can survive and so do I think she
went through no okay I want to commend
you for your work on that show and Damon
Lindelof it's so phenomenal thank you it
was one of the greatest experiences of
my life and it was life-changing now I
get to jump into why I get to talk to
you today I thought your work in the
first two episodes were fantastic thank
you cannot wait to watch episode three
and you also I believe directed the
finale I did so my question for you is
what is it like making a show that has
the two season pick up well oh that's
really interesting you know I never
really think about that at all I I don't
like to you know if you thought about
hey I'm gonna do two seasons of this
that many things would cross your mind
one is the pressure of it you know will
people like it am i doing a good job are
we telling the story the way it needs to
be told and thirdly like oh my god this
is way too hard to do again you know it
was a very difficult show to mount and
but there's so much more story to tell
so I'm really excited about two seasons
one of the things that the making of the
first season of any show you're kind of
figuring out the infrastructure of how
to make it what you can do in your
shooting schedule what you can
accomplish with your scripts what did
you learn
at the beginning what did you sort of
learn as the season was going on about
the making of the morning show well
exactly that you know you really learn
how many days you need to shoot it you
really learn how you know far you can
exhaust a scene and how long you know
you you learn like what is the short
what is the you know visual language of
a story of how you're trying to tell
this story what is that what are you
trying to define visually and how best
can you do it
within the hours you have to do it in
without sacrificing anything you know
because sometimes you have to shoot
something a certain way you want to
shoot it this way but no you have to
shoot it this way and sometimes shooting
it that way so much better than what you
originally thought because of time
constraints because of for multiple of
reasons and so the lesson is as a
filmmaker is always to keep your mind
open and always keep your heart open and
plan plan plan and then be ready for
anything
sure one last thing you sure right
before we ran out of time I'm obsessed
with the editing room because yes
because that's ultimately the final
rewrite where it all comes together how
did these episodes possibly change in
the editing room and is this the kind of
show that had a lot of deleted scenes or
not at all that's really interesting you
know this you do make a show a movie you
do tell a story three times you write it
and then you direct it and shoot it and
then you recreate it in the editing room
I feel the structure of this show was so
well written there were very few
structural changes we made we omitted
scenes and what's really interesting and
I'm very proud of is we never went back
for reshoots and never reshot anything
not even an insert so editorially of
course it's a process and you massage
and you massage and you know you get it
to the best place it can be and
sometimes you think oh my god the scene
is the worst it's just not working it's
horrible
and all of a sudden it becomes the most
favorite best scene you've ever done
just because you've had the time to
manipulate it Louis and find it and
that's what's beautiful about editing
and we had some beautiful editors on our
show starting with Carol Kravitz who did
the pilot in Episode two and the finale
with me and Alicia Ferraro and really
extraordinary editors like really
artists so it was great